just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world so imagine you're driving a car
all right maybe you're speeding
something like that you can pulled
over whatever the thing is right and
then cop comes by
hello it's a woman right ooh and you
recognize her oo because you're
subscribed only fans but she's a police
but she's a police offic now that's a
fun time is that a fun time that's a fun
time what are you thinking what are you
thinking in that exact moment I I'm
thinking exact moment I go Miss um
Michelle I I'm a fan I'm a big fan I
just be like oh my God I
subscribe yeah and then I go I really
like when you like lifted your leg and
um I I like when you like twist your
nipple a little
bit so you get real specific early to
prove it yeah yeah just be like just but
I would say specific things to let her
know I'm actually a fan and you're that
the highest tier no I'm at the highest
tier what if you tell her your username
I'm shy guy 32 and she's like oh my God
you're shy guy 32 like that'd be pretty
cool yeah and if she if she recognize it
then maybe maybe it's a good you know
I'm not going to pretend like I don't
don't know her yeah for sure cuz just
the other night you you have a VIP
access to her subscription cuz you're
you're at that tier you you've seen
videos of her and you think maybe your
husband the other guy must be your
husband or something like that um
watching a full sex video you know what
I mean and now you just got pulled over
like what's what's her credibility for
giving you a ticket in your eyes right
now The credibility well no she's a
police officer I I respect her you're
totally fine with that I'm totally fine
with that but a little bit I'm like what
okay now change roles all right all
right now you're the police commissioner
you're in charge of this officer and you
find out that one of your respected
deputies is also on Old fans respect is
a woman or a man the same woman the same
woman woman nor man same woman yeah you
you don't know these days and now you
find out through the news media Outlets
yeah that one of your distinguished and
well-respected cops is also on only fans
what do you do I'm who am I you're the
police commissioner I just said I'm the
commissioner okay I'm just making sure
yeah I'm you right okay I make sure
twice then three times is not okay okay
um I will say you know what I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to get a guide
you know to be like oh how could you do
this you're going to get a guy I'm going
to get a guy I'm going to hire a guy to
be like how can you do this film it
right and then get like all the news
people to write about it and then blow
it up and then go we need donation for
the police for because people are hating
on our thing and then we get more money
at the police station and she is the
face of our task force I have a question
what are the donations for for the
police things oh okay for you just did a
hate crime on our on our uh officer
officer hey C oh cuz you're like oh how
can you be a police officer if you do
the do it only fans and I would say I'm
a commissioner I go how can you say that
because she could also she does her job
really professionally yes she arrests
people and does a judge she has top 5%
of her whatever the thing is never get a
demerit and also yes she shows her [__]
but today what's the big whoop yeah
what's the big big whoop why would use
that line I'll go what's the big whoop
yeah what's cuz that it's playful you
know what I mean can you fire someone
for having a side hustle that's legal I
think that's legit dude if you're a good
cop I think you should [__] let her
ride it's like she's successful in two
things she gets the most arrest but she
also shows the most breast yeah and
what's the problem I like that run was
that intentional I just thought of it
pretty quickly cuz I was a former
rapper well this particular person who
did get pulled over by this cop uh was
saying to the news out there I wouldn't
want uh he said you can't arrest me no
more I've seen your private parts I
wouldn't want her to be arresting me and
I just saw you and your husband last
night for $29.99 have sex on only fans I
just can't respect you or the presinct
thing let me tell you something tase
them just tase them right away that's
what yeah tase them in the eyes tase
them and be like that would you respect
that [__] yeah you get you okay if they
do that you get shot in a kneecap one
time yeah if you say hey I can't respect
you do you respect this bullet yeah like
that that's very rude that he said that
rude he did say that to the news Outlet
or oh to the news Outlet a little puss
dude or if he goes sexual like that then
you pull out your gun and you blast his
[__]
nuts you take it sexual too cuz he
wanted to go sexual so he went to the
news outlets and kind of exposed her a
little bit kind of yeah dude what a
[__] [__] kind of huh I can't
respect you cuz I came all over to you
the other night there is now an
investigation though he goes well
internal investigation into this officer
I bet the whole precincts investigate
yeah they all got a sub they all
subscrib to her I feel like everybody
well not everybody I think a lot of
people do only fans now it is I think
we're going to hear more about that cuz
it's like it's such an easy way for
people to make money right is there so
everybody here on like morality issue
when it comes to like a uh you know a
person who's in service of the Greater
Community or whatever like that that's
supposed to enforce certain I think it
just matters on what you signed when you
took the job yeah if you're Integrity if
the guideline said you can't be nude on
a [__] pay site then maybe that was
their but would you but honestly which
most likely it doesn't say that in the
bylaws of a cop specifically but right
would you guys not do you really think
that would affect law enforcement though
like [__] yeah oh okay like even there's
that what is that like that JP Morgan
Chase CEO whatever he [__] DJs like
on the weekend people are tripping about
that cuz they're like dude you're
handling like billions and trillions of
dollars we don't need you coming into to
work [__] sleepy yeah you know so I
feel like there's certain things that
carry a certain amount of like implied
weight yeah so if there is that like you
probably don't want your eye surgeon to
be a DJ at night either but if you're
[__] if you if you're like um Bart's
got a thing against DJs at night well
cuz he's going to come and all [__]
sleeping he goes oh what was your name
again Joseph I mean Nick yeah yeah I'll
fix your eyes you're like what that's
what the commissioner said he's like
like so we found out you do only fans
but you better not be
DJ yeah some things carry implied weight
you know and it's not illegal but then
it also rubs people the wrong way if
you're but she's letting people rub the
right way with all of her content see
that though I can see that as like
people are just not going to respect
authority if you can literally see
Authority [__] on cam yeah it's not
doesn't go but if she tells you to
freeze you're going to freeze cuz you're
going to be like oo I will cuz you're
like I'm going to get my dick sucked and
then she's like taking you to jail you
get processed you're going like oh I
can't wait till I get my dick sucked and
then the whole time you're just like in
prison she goes man I'm going get my
dick sucked dude and then like the whole
time he didn't get his dick suck because
she just played
him I think if you're just [__] on
and sucking on cam I don't think that's
a big of a deal cuz it's like you're
probably [__] sucking outside of it
might tarnish a little bit of like the
community need credibility towards that
like Precinct it is because like if you
get pulled over and the person you can't
really keep a straight face and listen
cuz you're just like man you've been
sucking and [__] last night I saw you
I saw you going but what does that say
about you paying $30 a month to watch
them suck and [__] does that take your
credibility out of the way yeah but
you're an anonymous
username I know huh right but you're
paying to see that when you and your job
doesn't carry that weight that's true
that person is a person as a public who
are you to judge but what if their but
what if their like actions are like
really high like their their performance
is very top yeah like Top Cop what if
they're super cop yeah what if they're
good cop like they're not lazy cop
they're not lazy cop was doing like only
fans back in the day on super cop I
think that's good damn subscribed and
she she was doing really well at her job
and she did all responsibilities very
well but then at home when she's sucking
at [__] her husband she [__] films
it that's funny how the guy that
subscribed is like I lost respect and
it's like imagine this guy with his
pants around his ankles beating it off
and looking miserable and I'm all like
and that's resp and then he's going to
he's going to the news outlets and
talking [__] on this chick I'm like dude
you're the one subscribing dude so if
you guys were the police Commissioners
you're just going to like uhz and this
is public news now right you're going to
like back her up oh dude you're going to
lose your job if you don't do something
okay what about okay remember the cop
that talked about where she was [__]
everybody in the oh on head on head
didn't she just get suspended and then
she went back or did she get fired fir I
don't know I don't know why she should
have been suspended I mean she was
giving a lot of like therapy to the guy
it went back and forth a lot though
because initially yeah she got like
suspended but then she they tried to
spin a story saying that that she was
forced I might have to rewrite the
hiring [__] handbook if if I if I was
a commissioner cuz it's almost like
imagine this okay imagine you're the
commissioner of the [__] school the
school bus committee you're the boss and
yeah this guy's really good he's the
best bus driver that we've ever had
brings kids safe to school and home for
the last 20 years and then this guy
enters into a [__] bumper car
competition and this mother [__]
crashes into 45 cars it's technically
not illegal but now you're you don't
feel so safe putting your kids on the
school bus anymore I don't think that's
the same you know what I mean they're
just like some like I don't
know competition the goal of bumper cars
is to bump other cars okay how about
this they enter into a go-kart
competition and this will [__] killed
seven kids in the go-kart cover they're
spitting
around now we're talking about murder
what about if you're you're you're the
superintendent and then one of your
teachers just does only fans see that's
different I think
but what I would have to investigate the
content
[Applause]
what school male teacher doing baby
diaper
porn oh that's weird and he's a te
teachers is different because you're
with kids technically not legal the kids
but the kids can't be joined only fans
they have to be 18 plus anyway you're
things that come with it and that's the
part to hard to part to
juggle no sorry I'm just saying if
you're a cop and your job is to strictly
pull over people and give them tickets
when they're breaking the law what does
that have to do with you that's what I'm
saying and if you're high performing
what's the problem but if you're a
teacher and you're hanging out with kids
all the time and then you have only fans
then that's a little bit of a conflict
that day but you're only pulling over
people because that's your entry level
job your goal is to get higher and
higher detective or whatever the [__]
guy that gets pulled over he's and he's
talking [__] to the [__] only fans
cop while he subscribes like what does
that have to do you still broke the law
you still got pulled over you still ran
the red you still need to ticket you
know what I mean like of course I get
pulled over by cops and I'm like I
[__] hate you I want to punch you in
the face but then or I want to bust an
up to you because I'm subscribed but
even then it's like what are you going
to do yeah you got stuck with a ticket
I'm just saying if you're the
superintendent though you know and this
is like public it's on him it's on him
thing yeah he also didn't play it very
well cuz if I was a subscriber and I got
pulled over I would comply the whole way
through and then go can take a picture
get
it big fan big fan would you would you
he's kind of a [__] ass for out top
would you take out taica from a class if
the teacher was a vlogger and he was
always like vlogging and going taica is
drove me nuts today yeah he's using your
kid for Content yeah cuz he's such a
character he's like clout chasing cuz T
has a bigger
following he can you tag me ta ta can
you tag me he was a YouTuber he's a good
teacher oh he's a good teacher he's a
great teacher but then on the offside
talking [__] about your son on Vlogs
that's [__] up does it come back
around does it like does like another
fifth grader come and like beat up taica
because like I watched Mr Vlogs when he
said you're different identity that
nobody knows he never says ta's name but
he's like there's this [__] half
asian half Latino Kid in class half
Latino half Asian dude that's tough I
don't know cuz if if taica is crushing
it like if the result of his class and
taica is actually doing well he is yeah
I might be like might need to keep init
on him but the content's sick super good
content it's [__] funny it's like
Casey nice that [__]
and then they they tag editing and music
they tag your channel yeah and then I'd
probably agree too I'd be like yeah t is
a piece of [__] huh he's kind of [__]
up maybe we'll do a collab you want to
collab with my Vlog Channel sitting
there talking
[__] and then you're like can I get some
extra lessons for him yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah